Hello 大家好欢迎大家来到[来源标识已去除]出品的拼多多商家成长训练营我们今天讲第九节的内容平台核心规则的红线认知那今天呢我们会按照情节轻重把平台的核心红线规则拆明白从轻微违规到永久封禁每一集的坑在哪罚多少怎么避免我们一次性把它讲透帮助我们大家能够守住店铺
那首先我们需要明确一个核心的逻辑拼多多的轻微违规处罚是阶梯式的他首次可能是以轻微违规只是罚款警告如果是重复采信或者是情节非常严重的呢会面临直接关店追责所以咱们先从最容易采的情节较轻的红线来说起那轻微违规的话我们的定义标准是什么呢
高处罚但是处罚是可控的那处罚多以罚款加上轻微限制为主下面我们又分了四个三个小类第一个是我们的发货时效发货时效的处罚其实在于我们拼多多店铺经营的过程中是非常常见的发货时效又分为延迟发货虚假发货虚假物流轨迹以及我们的商品缺货板块是以这四类为主的
我们先看第一个延迟发货
延迟发货
它是以未开通发货时效权益的普通订单
超过48小时之内没有发货和揽收信息
我们就算是延迟发货
那它处罚的标准是300元以下的订单呢
是罚3元
300元以上会按照1%赔
那最多是赔30块钱
它是有一个封顶的上限的
还有是上传物流单号后24小时之内满收记录的
没有满收记录的
这个是属于虚假发货
虚假发货呢
它也是按照实收订单金额的25%发
最低是5块钱
最高是100元
那这个钱是从我们的店铺余额或者保证金里面扣
直接是以平台无门槛券的形式来发放给我们的买家
第三个虚假物流轨迹
虚假物流轨迹是只有满收记录以后
24小时之内它没有分拨中心到转运中心的更新记录
它一直卡在一个地方
那这种呢我们属于虚假物流轨迹
虚假物流轨迹它是按照订单时收金额的25%
最低5元最高100元
这个规则是跟我们的虚假发货规则是一样的
包括它的罚款标准也是一样的
但是对于我们店铺层面的处罚
它其实是分轻度重度和重度
如果说占比超过30%的话
全店资金都会受到限制
并且会移除资源位
商品下架 禁止暴活动
那如果是重度的话
就会多次违规 冻结全部货款
那下面我们再看一下商品缺货
商品缺货自己跟平台或者买家说
没有货了发不了
甚至让买家加价换货 取消订单等等
这些是属于商品缺货
或者是什么呢
已经延迟发货了
都过了三天到五天
上传单货了到五天内都没有
没有物流轨迹
没有发货的情况下
也会被判罚成缺货
商品缺货的处罚金额跟以上物流轨迹罚款
以及虚假物流都不一样
普通订单的话
100元以赔付5元一单
100元以上是按照5%的金额去赔
最多的话上线封顶是100元
活动订单是100元以内赔10元
100元以上是按照10%去赔
最高赔付1000元
特殊订单比如说像定制的家居统一赔付5元一单
百亿补贴的订单是100元以内是赔10元
100元以上是按10%赔
最高是300元
如果是情节非常严重的
会直接清退店铺并且会扣除所有的保证金
那么赔付形式其实都是差不多的
都是从商家的账户去扣除
以50年有效期的无门槛券发放给买家
这个是属于我们的物流发货时效的轻微违规
还有一种第二种是链接瑕疵
链接瑕疵是属于比如说什么呢
链接描述不规范
主图有错别字或者详情页
主图用了最佳顶级这种绝对化的极限词语
它第一次会被平台通知整改
商品面临降权
第二次的话会直接下架限制推广
还有就是类目错放的话
如果被抓到了以后也会被要求整改
但是像类目错放这种的话
它都是不会影响店铺整体权重
它只是单个链接会受到影响
那第三种就是我们的活动旅约
活动旅约的话是要求活动内参与的订单
需要在约定时间内发货
如果是缺货的话会被平台扣除活动保证金
用于赔偿消费者都是属于平台的轻微违规
轻微违规 轻微违规的话我们这里有一个避坑指南
首先我们要明确我们的自己的链接库存及时发货
并且是需要预留一定的揽收时间的
那我们可以多合作几家快递公司
因为单一快递公司可能会面临某些地区停发
以及物流时效在某个节点可能会出现问题
那我们多合作几家快递公司可以大大降低这样的风险
那在第二点呢 链接在发布前我们需要去多核对几遍
比如说错别字呀 虚假宣传呀 虚标呀之类的问题
还有类目的问题 我们可以多核对几遍
基本上也能避免90%这样的问题出现
那轻微违规说完了以后呢 我们要看一下情节中等的情况是属于哪些
我们这里有一个定义 刻意违规或者是重复采线的情况下
我们会把它给判定为情节中等
那在这类商家的话 要不就是明知误犯 要不就是
因为违规没有及时整改 导致重复触发 使我们的处罚升级为高额罚款 加功能限制 加降权
那像这种情况 我们需要重点警惕以下这六种分类
第一种 虚假宣传与信息造假 比如说食品宣传能够降糖 美妆说百分百能去豆 或者是主图有虚标
明明是1000毫升 但实际上只有500毫升
那种情况呢 商品第一次被抓到的话会下价30天 第二次的话会直接冻结近30天销售额的10%到30%不等的货款
或者是入住的时候用的过期的资质 申诉时上传假的物流抵单
第一次都会扣除1000元 第二次会扣除1000元加店铺降权7天
这个都是属于虚假宣传及信息造假
那第二种是虚假 普通的虚假交易
这里我们指的是什么
就是S单被抓
你像我们找亲友或者是找刷手去刷单
或者是用同一IP地址重复下单
像刷单被抓呢
我们研究第一次可能会扣除对应的保证金
限制货款提现15天
第二次被平台发现了
会限制参加平台活动90天
店铺的信用等级会从优质降到普通
第三次的话
我们可能会面临着店铺直接清退的一个风险
平台会通过我们的IP轨迹
支付账号以及我们关联店铺会识别到刷单
别要抱有任何侥幸心理
第三点
质量抽减不合格
质量抽减不合格的话
这里也会分为几种情况
如果是一般的质量问题
比如说衣服做工粗糙
或者是五金件轻微生锈等这些问题
情况不是很严重的
平台一般会先要求商品下架整改
但是如果是涉及安全不合格
比如说电器漏电 食品添加剂 超标等这种属于情节比较严重的
平台涉及到罚款的情况下
那罚款的金额会按照店铺近30天的交易额
30% 50%甚至是百分百的比例不等
会以这种形式去进行罚款
而且还会被全网通报
这个是质量抽检不合格
第四点呢
我们的物流严重违规
物流严重违规
前面我们有说到轻微违规里面
其实也有包含几种物流违规
但是这里的物流违规
我们重点说的是什么
就是欺诈发货
比如说发空包
给买家寄一个空盒子
泡沫 废纸
根本就没有实际的商品
或者是货不对版
发的东西和商品的描述完全不一样
买家买的是手机
发耳机
买正装发小样等等
数量如果有严重差值超过50%的也算
比如说拍了10件
但是实际上我们只发了3件
那这种情况下的话
买家通过聊天信息
或者是和平台反馈的情况下
我们都是属于货不对版
会被判罚
那第三种
比如说恶意欺诈发货
故意发一些无关紧要的杂物
破旧的报纸啊
这些之类的都算是欺诈发货
三次会罚500到2000元
三次以上是直接会店铺清退
包括物流造假
用广州的单号发北京的单号
都会被判定为虚假交易扣除保证金
包括店铺降权60天
在这里的话我们需要重点警惕一点的是
一旦被判定为虚假欺诈发货
我们不仅要承担单订单的赔付
我们还会面临店铺连带的处罚
冻结店铺的货款，限制提现，禁止上薪
包括像单商品单日欺诈发货超过20单 占比超过5%的话
全店订单按照欺诈发货处理 多次违规是直接清店的
所以这里的话 物流严重违规的欺诈发货这一块
大家一定要重点关注一下
那第五点就是我们的知识产权 轻度侵权
知识产权的侵权我们其实是分两个板块的
第二个是它如果是重度的话它到平台高压线那个板块那个层面
如果只是轻度的话我们经常可能会遇到的是什么
倒图 倒用别人自己拍的图片或者是冒充一些品牌的logo擦边
但是我们把它改个字也是啄木鸟
但是它只是擦了个边
这种它是属于轻度侵权的
平台也是会要求整改或者是下架链接
六个月内不能上新
如果是清权的商品销量比较高呢
还会要求赔付品牌方损失
但是这种情况下一般会很少有
如果我们只是擦边的话
平台会要求整改会比较多一点
或者是直接让我们换图
第六个呢就是诱导非官方交易
我们店铺在客服考试的那个环节
基本上24题里面呢
有60%以上的题目
都是给我们明确一点
就是不允许诱导非官方的交易
信息交流在聊天商品业包裹宣传当中呢
引导客户留微信QQ手机号码或者是第三方平台的链接
二维码这种或者是非平台的收款码
这些是严令禁止的
像引导支付宝啊微信啊私下转账这种
还有一种是被动违规
就是接受用户提出的平台以外的交易
并且请求配合执行
这一种也会被判定违规
所以我们现在的客户聊天信息或者在我们做链接的过程中一定要规范
平台现在的稽查是非常严格的
如果是被判罚了以后
它会以什么样的标准呢
那第一次是属于一般违规的范畴
它最多是限制货款提现
商品下架降权
禁止上薪或者是上任何资源位
以及会让我们的保证金直接加到五万
之前的话我们也会有遇到很多客户说
在群里和我们反馈
说为什么平台会要求他们加保证金
其实就是被抓到了
被平台抓到了
可能会有私下和客户交易
包括我们给客户打电话的隐私号
全程的沟通也是会被平台监控的范围
所以在这里的话
第二次犯了以后呢
平台只会让我们去加电保证金
或者对我们店铺进行限制
降权的限制
一般不会有一些实质的处罚
但是如果是多次或者严重违规
被平台抓到了以后呢
平台会冻结我们的全部后盘
全店商品禁售
禁售直接会清退店铺
这种是像诱导费官方交易这种
它是给予你很多次机会
才会直接面临这种
限制店铺
清退店铺的这种处罚
所以我们把它放在了
情节中等的这个板块里面
那像这种六种情况的
这种六种情况的
注意的红线呢
我们有一个避坑指南
首先我们要严禁造假刷单和盗用
一些平台的一些图片之类的东西
我们要保证我们自己的链接
宣传是真实有效的
不要夸大宣传
也不要虚标我们的产品功效
第三个呢
我们要求我们的物流是真实有效的
千万不要欺诈发货
不要虚假发货
第四个话是我们收到了平台的违规通知
要求我们去整改
必须要第一时间去整改
千万不要拖
有一些东西拖严重了以后
他第一次只是警告他第二次会加重你的处罚
这样也是非常不好的
这以上六点呢
是我们的情节中等的情况下
那第三种呢
是我们的平台的高压线
非常情况严重的情况下是什么呢
我们这里有个定义是零容忍
处级就会立马封电
根本就不会给你机会
还有第一次第二次第三次没有
只要是被平台抓到了
立马就会罚款或者封电
处罚呢是永久封电加追责
有的时候我们我们会觉得
可能最多平台只是会冻结资金会罚款对吗
其实不止
如果要是碰到了平台的高压线
它甚至会有追责
会负一些法律责任
会负一些刑事责任的风险
这里我们要重点要求大家明确一点
有以下三个方面
第一个方面是我们的商品售假以及严重侵权
我们在第二点
情节充满当中我们有说过
轻微侵权其实是有整改机会的
但是严重侵权是非常的会被追责的
会面临负一些刑事和法律方面的风险
比如说像无品牌
无品牌授权的商品
你卖耐克 华为等大品牌的商品
但是你没有授权
或者是销售专利侵权的一些核心商品
被抓到了以后是会被直接永久封店的
保证金权额扣除的情况下
法人还会被列入拼多多的黑名单
永久都不能再开店
如果是涉及到一些知名品牌
还会被移交市场监管部门
面临着行政处罚
以及要负一些刑事责任
可能会被起诉等等
包括像盗版书籍 软件或者是质量极差
失去使用功能
但是却谎称是正品售卖的东西
这些东西都是包含在售假与严重侵权的范围之内的
第二点 恶意 虚假 交易 套取补贴
就是套取平台的这些优惠券
像拼多多平台的话
它跟其他平台可能最大的一个不一样的板块就是
拼多多它会给到我们的买家很多的平台补贴
有一些是平台和商家合资出券
有一些是平台自己给予的商家一些补贴券的形式来促进
我们比如说有一些商家如果要是组织刷手批量刷单
虚假交易订单如果一旦是超过5%的情况下
或者是设置高价商品去诱导我们的用户用券以后反差价
这种都是属于套取平台补贴
那么会按照套取金额的10倍罚款
像这种情况是上不封顶的
罚款是上不封顶
并且会同时永久终止于平台的合作
有一些店群的商家他会有什么多店关联刷单
那这种情况下是全部店群是被同步封禁的
保证金也会全部扣除
所以这个罚款是比较严重的
它会连带着有关联店铺的同时惩罚
第三个我们的税务与资质的严重违规
因为我们现在电商也是越来越合法化了
我们从2025年开始提出来有正式需要交税的一个政策以来
我们就在税务这个板块呢 它会越来越正规
所以我们平台呢 对于税务的报送板块也是非常的 管得会非常的严
包括商家引力收入 私户收款 不申报纳税
都会被平台自动会上报给税务局
税务局呢 它会精准捕捉
那到时候呢 不仅要什么 补税 而且还要缴质纳金
还会被 如果情节严重就会被平台封禁店铺嘛
因为偷税漏税太严重了
他就会空间店铺把从线上的问题是移交到我们线下的税务部门去处理了
那第二个就是资质造假
包括 但不仅限于什么呢
营业执照 食品经营许可证或者是一些核心资质造假
平台一经发现就会终止合作并且会追究起法律责任
资质造假这一块也是非常严重的
那像我们以上说的这三点
我们有一个避坑指南会建议商家坚决不要碰售假套补贴和造假资质这种行为
因为这些行为不仅会让我们多年的经营成果归零
而且还会面临我刚刚说的牢狱之灾
要负刑事责任
这个完全是得不偿失的
那我们总结一下以上我们说的这三点
拼多多的红线规则的核心呢
它其实是什么
阶梯式处罚
加上关联追责
一般轻微的话我们要做到什么
及时整改
中等呢我们是要坚决的避免
严重的情节是碰都不能碰
所以经营店铺呢
有的时候它就像我们开车一样
只有遵守一定的规则才能走得更远
相信2026年的平台规则会要求越来越严
你与其想着怎么去钻空子
不如把精力放在选品优化服务和合规经营上面
才是长久之道
这就是我们第九节的平台核心规则红线认知
下节课再见